a student builds a circuit with a
battery and two light bulbs in series
then the student builds a second circuit
with two light bulbs in parallel which
battery runs out of power first assume
all bulbs have equal resistance assume
both batteries have equal electrical
potential all right so let's just think
about this before we even look at the
choices so the first scenario you have
your battery positive terminal negative
terminal and you have two light bulbs in
series so let's just draw it this way
and traditional light bulbs really are
just resistors that when a current goes
through them they get hot enough and
that's because of the energy dissipated
that the emit visible light so that's
the first resistor or the first light
bulb the second one and it goes back so
that's the first scenario the second
scenario looks like this so plus minus
where they are in parallel they are in
parallel just like that and they say
assume all bulbs have equal resistance
so we could just call their resistances
R just like that and we assume that both
of these batteries are for the sake of
argument identical so one way to think
about it is what is going to be the
equivalent resistance for these circuits
this one when you have two resistors in
series you could simplify or you could
view this circuit as you have your
voltage source which is our battery and
you could model it as a circuit with one
resistor where it's resistance is 2r if
you wanted to think of an equivalent for
this parallel circuit you have your same
voltage source and you could model it as
having a resistor there and what would
this resistance be what is equivalent to
these two resistances in parallel so if
we call this resistance sub two we know
that one over resistance sub two is
equal to one over R plus one over R and
this is the formula for equivalent
resistance when you have resistors in
parallel
and so this is going to be equal to two
over R and so if you just take the
reciprocal of this and this you get R 2
is equal to R over 2 so this is equal to
R over 2 now what is the power
dissipated across a resistor we know let
me just do this in a different color
power dissipated across a resistor is
going to be the voltage across the
resistor times the current going through
that resistor well we know that the
voltage across both of these resistances
is going to be the same so V is going to
be the same in either situation but what
about the current well we know that V is
equal to IR so in the or another way to
think about it is current is equal to
voltage over resistance so our current
in this first scenario is going to be V
over 2r while our current in this second
scenario is going to be V over R over 2
which is the same thing as 2 V over R so
our current in this second scenario is
going to be 4 times as large so if you
quadruple the current and you have the
same voltage well you're going to
quadruple the power and so if you're
quadrupling the power you're quadrupling
the amount of energy that's dissipated
per unit time and so in this second
scenario where we've quadrupled of the
power we're quadrupling the energy
dissipated over time that battery is
going to run out a lot faster so when
they asked which battery runs out of
power first well that's going to be the
battery in the circuit with two
lightbulbs in parallel and we're done